in this video i'm gonna be breaking down
the eighth episode of attack on titan
season four
in which gabby killed a beloved member
of the scouts that we've known for years
cementing her plays as one of the new
most hated characters in the series
this video will explain everything that
i thought was interesting about the
episode
including reiner's weird titan form
gabby's motivations
and zeke jaeger betraying marley zeke's
portrayal has been hinted at throughout
the season
so i'll be breaking down all the
foreshadowing we got regarding this
reveal
and obviously if you haven't already be
sure to hit that sub button so you don't
miss the latest breakdowns
okay so episode 8 was called assassin's
bullet but before we talk about the
assassination in question
the opening scene showed us the return
of the armored titan after hearing the
cries of two annoying children
rhino reluctantly came back from the
brink of death to try and save poco
but i mean as you can see you know his
titan looks way different than usual
his armor was just taking a much longer
time to manifest so rina had a lot of
bare flesh that wasn't protected
not to mention his usual armored mouth
guard was nowhere to be seen
this form was obviously not an upgrade
of any kind but rather it was the
negative consequence of reiner only
half-heartedly waking up
aaron and reiner then have the titan
equivalent of an old western standoff
before the attack titan easily breaks
his draw with one punch
because there was less armor protecting
it in case you haven't been counting
that's the second time this season that
aaron has attacked someone
prior to them fully transforming anyway
the weakened armored titan was still
able to grab poco and save his life
showing us that aaron was more concerned
about giving his nemesis a beat down
than he was about eating the draw titan
after all he could have just taken this
bite a lot quicker if he really wanted
it badly
having now repaid galliard for saving
his life back at fort's lava
reiner collapses to the ground whilst
aaron and mikasa hitcher ride onto the
airship
hanji said in the last episode that
anyone who didn't board the airship in
time
would be left behind in mali so it was
kind of important that aaron didn't
waste any more time fighting
especially as both him and rhino were
out of strength upon arriving on this
thing
aaron and armin share a really
down-hearted looking glance with each
other
and you can understand why armin has
mixed feelings here because he had to
kill
thousands of people because someone
decided to get the survey core involved
with his plan
aaron is then pleasantly greeted by
captain levi who kicks him in the face
and immediately has him detained
the reason he's getting restrained is
because the attack on mali was his
idea and the scouts were basically
forced to go along with it because
without eren they have no future
that's why hanji was upset with him
later in the episode because aaron went
off to do his own thing in mali
hoping that his friends would bail him
out no matter how many people would die
in the process
when levi kicked aaron's face that was a
throwback to the trial in season 1
in which levi kicked the crap out of him
to show people that he could be
controlled
but now in the present day it looks like
he just did it because he's angry with
aaron for getting the scouts into this
mess
i love how both times this happened
armin is the one who has to restrain
mikasa like
sometimes even armin knows that aaron
needs to get beaten up for the greater
good
as the airship continues to escape the
scout's protected from incoming fire
but marley no longer has any guns that
could bring the ship down
their anti-titan cannons would have done
the trick but as you can see they were
blown up a few episodes ago
so everything is currently going
according to plan various scouts begin
to get on board
but one person who stays out a little
bit longer is the former commander lobov
although he is a minor character his
story is quite interesting because it
represents how some people on the island
have changed
after the secrets of the world were
revealed now that he knows there is a
world outside parodies island
lobov resigned from his position as a
commander in the garrison and joined the
survey corps to make a difference
flock is another character that has
drastically changed during the time skip
as beforehand he was a coward by his own
admission but nowadays he is a full-on
elder nationalist
he went out of his way to maximize
damage against mali during this mission
not to mention that he is arguably the
most passionate about their victory
and later on it was him who proposed the
idea of throwing gabby and falco off the
airship
yeah we need to keep an eye on this
character during the celebrations
connie waved a massive death flag when
he made it clear that he was especially
grateful that sasha and jon survived
and uh yeah surely at that point
everyone knew that at least one of them
was going to die right
down on the ground gabby continues to
follow the airship having set out to do
so during the opening scene
but falco falls behind her in an attempt
to make her stop
although we already knew most of gabby's
motivations for wanting to kill the
scouts such as the death of her friends
and her pre-existing hatred for everyone
from parodies there was still one thing
in her speech that caught my attention
the real reason that gabby was fully
willing to die during this episode
was because she dreamed of a day when
aldians could be proud to wear those
armbands
but after eren's massacre she knows that
they will never come
how could aliens ever be considered
equal to regular human beings
when just one eldian was able to
single-handedly kill
politicians military leaders and
obviously innocent civilians
what eren has done is just irreversible
so in this moment gabby no longer really
cares about inheriting the armored titan
her main goal is getting revenge which
again is one of the ways she mirrors a
young vengeful eren
unlike gabby falco's brainwashing from
mali has been slightly undone thanks to
the words of mr jaeger
as he understands that aliens from
parodies are retaliating for what was
done to them
and that all aliens are the same
regardless of whether they're born in
mali or if they're born in parodies
it caused ryan to have a mental
breakdown when he came to that same
realization
so kudos to falco for not freaking out
more scouts begin to board the airship
during the escape
but when loboth and gabby come face to
face he hesitates to shoot her because
she's a child
just like how sasha chose not to take
the shot against gabby as well
that's two times now that gabby's life
has been spared by someone who she then
went on to kill
as gabby gets her first kill of the
episode it provided a unique opportunity
because lobos odm gear was still
tethered to the airship gabby knew that
going onto this ship would be a suicide
mission
but she is willing to die to get that
revenge colt appears just before gabby
pulls the trigger
and the last time we saw him he said he
was going to look for falco having
finally found his younger brother
colt could only watch on in horror as
falco risked his life for gabby again
by zipping onto the airship alongside
her if falco was my younger brother i
would honestly be so sick of this crap
like this is the third time that we know
of where he's intentionally done
something like this
his actions were spurred on by what
reiner said to him about protecting
gabby
although given falco's track record i'm
sure he still would have done this exact
same thing
even if rainer didn't say that once they
made it onto the airship
gabby quickly takes aim at sasha and
gets her revenge by shooting her with
the rifle
there's a few things we need to unpack
here regarding gabby and sasha's brief
history so let's just start from the
beginning
during dinner in the braun household
reiner was asked by gabby's father about
the devils on the island
and the first person ryan mentioned to
his family was the girl who ate a potato
during the entrance ceremony
gabby was listening the whole time but i
don't think even she imagined that she'd
be killing these people so soon
a few episodes later gabby and sasha
made eye contact after sasha killed the
malian security guards
and we know for a fact that gaby liked
these guys because they cared for her
safety even though she was an aldian
this headshot from sasha was the final
straw that turned gabby into an
unstoppable force for revenge
and i find it ironic that sasha was
killed with a weapon belonging to the
man that she killed herself
as a member of the 104th cadet corps
potato girl was a character that we've
known since the early days of the series
and we saw she grew from a quirky and
occasionally mistakeful character
into one of the bravest and most
reliable soldiers that the scouts have
one thing that never changed about her
even during this episode was her
relentless obsession with food
so it's pretty fitting that her last
word was just meat
as everyone was just reacting to sasha
getting shot gabby and jean immediately
tried to kill each other
and they probably would have both died
if falco didn't intervene
the kids then get beat up by a group of
soldiers and i felt sorry for falco in
this scene because he really didn't do
anything
but yeah gabby definitely deserved it
sasha was slowly beating
out as connie tried to keep her awake
and this is even more heart-wrenching
when you remember
that sashi is basically the closest
thing he has to family i mean his mother
is technically alive although she is a
pure titan
but the rest of his family are all gone
so losing sasha is almost like losing a
sister to him
moving on a recovering peak finally
begins to remember details about the
malian soldier who trapped her
underground
and know that soldier was not armin
despite that being a popular fan theory
in the comments
earlier this season zeke mentioned how
there were 32 malian ships that never
returned
after being sent to check out parodies
island and this soldier was on one of
those missing ships
to be specific the soldier's name is
elena and she was part of the very first
group of ships that were sent to check
out parodies three years
ago in pique's flashback we can see that
yelena was standing next to this guy
who is the one piloting the airship that
the scouts are currently in
therefore based on current information
we know for a fact that at least two
malian soldiers have now switched sides
after going to parody's island and it
seems that now they are working against
mali
rather than formally the reason pique
remembers elena
is because she is a follower of zeke
meaning that her true loyalties were
always to him
rather than the malian military we're
not exactly sure how peek knows that
information
but the main point is that she was
already suspicious of elena prior to the
current events
this confirms why she was able to
vaguely remember elena despite that
terrible beard
and also it confirms that peak was
suspicious of zeke as well
after all if pique fully trusted zeke
then why would she be suspicious of
someone who followed him
like the only logical explanation is
that pique always had
some doubts about zeke and was therefore
keeping tabs on his followers
this was the part of the episode where
we got the double reveal that zeke
jaeger has been secretly working with
paradise
and that he did survive the attack from
levi in the last episode
before we continue it should be clear
that zeke has not always been working
with the island
otherwise he wouldn't have done certain
things like you know wiping out ninety
percent of the survey core
since the beginning of the season it's
been obvious that the alien race is
growing more and more at risk
as the power of the titans is beginning
to become more irrelevant
when titans truly become useless then so
will the aliens themselves
and it's possible they could suffer more
than they currently do whatever zeke and
aaron have planned their goal would be
to reduce the suffering of aldians one
way or another
and this is possible now that they have
the founding titan and a titan of royal
blood
the last time both those elements were
in one place aaron was able to use the
full power of the founding titan
which also gives him the ability to
destroy the world with the wall titans
by having that power the island safety
should be guaranteed to an extent
because i mean who is going to come and
invade when you have the power to
destroy the world
anyway like i said in the intro zeke's
betrayal of mali has been subtly hinted
at throughout the season
with my favorite example being during
episode 4. in that episode
falco noticed that aaron had a baseball
glove and a baseball and asked him if
his family sent it to him
back in season 3 there was an episode
titled perfect game
with the title itself being a reference
to baseball terminology
during perfect game the beast titan held
rocks at the scouts several times
making baseball references throughout
and this kind of implied that zeke was a
fan of the sport
aaron having this gear subtly showed us
that zeke was the family member that he
was referring to and it was a clue that
they were now working together
another hint at zeke's portrayal
happened during the battle in liberio
in which he straight up says eren yeager
is not my enemy
even though it seemed like he was saying
it in jest we can now see that he
literally meant what he said
and peak's expression tells us that she
was probably suspecting something as
well
although to be fair porko also was kind
of shocked he also gave away his true
motives when he said that levi was
running out of time
as this was referring to the escape plan
they had in place we saw how levi was
checking his stopwatch
so basically zeke was reminding him
almost that you know you need to attack
me soon or else i won't be able to
escape
the plan to betray marley was set into
motion from episode 2
as zeke pushed the agenda to invade
parodies island it was because of this
suggestion
that the festival was later held in
liberia to declare war providing aaron
with the perfect battleground to do what
he needed to do
and for the scouts to swoop in and take
zeke to the island the plan was that
elena would take the draw and cart titan
out of the battle
hence why zeke didn't go with them as
they got trapped because those two
escaped
zika could pretend like he was genuinely
trying to kill the scouts
hence why he threw more rocks than he
was supposed to also if you're wondering
how he survived this attack from levi
it's because the captain sliced off his
limbs and then quickly pulled away his
body during the explosion i had so many
people asking me if levi committed
suicide in this moment
because when the way he kind of appears
in the anime you see the explosion but
you don't see levi get away
and i think the reason we didn't see
levi is because he would have been
holding zeke's body that would have
given away the surprise a bit too early
so i think
that's the reason why we didn't see
going back to sasha's death
the reaction of armin and mikasa was a
great depiction of genuine grief
which is something that attack on titan
has always done really well jon points
out that sasha's death was a direct
consequence of aaron going rogue by
himself
and whilst aaron is clearly hurt by this
he lets out a pain laugh
at hearing her final words the word meat
reminded him of that funny memory from
before the battle of trust
when sasha essentially risked getting
locked up by stealing meat from the
office's pantry
it was a wholesome memory that was
pretty much just classic sasha
and i feel that aaron really didn't know
how to react especially knowing that he
is responsible for what happened
the look on his face reminded me of that
timey kiss his story at hand just
straight up pain
with that said that was my review of
episode 8 of attack on titan season 4
which was honestly a roller coaster of
an episode as usual i'd appreciate if
you dropped a like if you like this
video
and share it with anyone who you think
might enjoy it thanks for watching as
always and until the next one
peace out